all right so you like me might have seen
a lot of Formula 1 recently a lot of
races a lot of famous drivers a lot of
drama and exciting stories it's taken
over my timeline on Twitter many times
basically a ton of you guys have been
sending it to me asking hey are you
watching are you paying attention to
this stuff and uh so I finally caved and
I've started watching it and I'm really
glad I did so in this video I'm going to
tell you guys why I think Formula 1 is
super cool why I started watching and
while you should probably be watching
Formula 1 too from the stories to the to
the tech to The Innovation to the race
day
experiences this is Formula 1
[Music]
letl so shout out to sponsor bid
Defender for making this video possible
they reached out because they are a
Ferrari team partner so they're on the
Ferrari car and the helmet and they have
a lot of parallels in the tech world
with cyber security and safety so we'll
talk more about that in a minute but for
now I'm so glad that y'all put this on
my radar because I love it now just
because while while on the surface it is
just a car race which is already pretty
cool it is also at the same time the
world's highest end Tech competition
it's a science fair so at the most basic
level the sport is a year-long season of
car races on different tracks around the
world and Formula 1 has a long and Rich
history I don't need to give you a whole
history lesson here but there's been a
massive amount of changes going from
stuff like this like a pretty simple
looking tube with an engine and wheels
to
this aerodynamic work of art made from
the most advanced materials on the
planet but the most interesting part
about F1 that I love is that there are
actually two championships at the same
time each season there's the driver's
championship and the constructor's
championship so yes every driver is
going to try to get around the track as
fast as possible but the structure is
there are 10 teams each team has two
active drivers and so every race a
driver can get points for how high they
finish those add up at the end of the
season to get a winner but there's also
points for the engineering teams behind
each car and they also get points that
add up to a championship at the end of
the year and this this is what I mean
when I say it's a science fair cuz look
every sport has rules right every like
golf all your clubs need to be within a
certain spec and the basketball hoop is
standardized right but having the best
equipment in F1 is incredibly
advantageous as you might suspect and
you're allowed actually encouraged even
to improve your equipment between every
single race you are constantly working
on your equipment in so many ways F1 is
the sport with the most tech involved
like these teams are spending millions
and millions hundreds of millions of
dollars to find SL invent any little
Improvement that they can come up with
to give themselves The Edge every single
week they're fighting for tenths and
hundredths of a second it's incredible
to see like you don't get from from here
to here so quickly by accident there is
a massive amount of engineering and
experimenting that goes into optimizing
every single little part of every car to
be able to get around the track as fast
as physically possible to get as many
points for the championship every season
within the rules and yes there are still
rules this is important so the FIA is
the governing body in charge of F1 and
they are charged with the impossible
task of maintaining a set of rules that
keeps every
fair and safe but still allows room for
and encourages Innovation and tweaking
things so you can actually look up the
rule book yourself there's 183 page pdf
online I'll leave a link below like
button if you want to flip through it
yourself and there are so many
interesting rules in here some of them
to keep racing strategies interesting
like the requirement that every single
driver uses at least two different tire
compounds during the race I'll explain
that in a minute there are also plenty
of safety related rules which again is
why a company like Bit Defender really
makes sense to be here so these are Open
Wheel open cockpit race cars but every
single one of them as you'll see no
matter what has this iron reinforced
ring around and above the driver's head
called a Halo this thing is not designed
by the teams this is designed by the FIA
and the teams get them from one of the
approved manufacturers and they have to
put them on their car there was
initially some push back against the
Aesthetics of it but every single year
since its introduction in 2018 it's
continued to prove its worth in the
safety department like you can literally
go watch race footage of incidents where
the Halo saves lives since it can
literally support the weight of another
entire car on top of you or if it gets
flipped upside down so you can bet
that's why Bit Defender wanted their
logo specifically on the Halo of the
team Ferrari car so Bit Defender is a
leader in cyber security which means
they value innovation safety and quick
reactions which is tied right into F1 so
you can see why it makes sense for Bit
Defender logo to be on the most
important safety features of the cars
they're also on the helmet too by by the
way there's some other highle rules
around the turbocharged V6 engines they
all use and the gearboxes ETC my
personal favorite and funniest rule to
me is also one of the oldest which is
under every single F1 car is a plank of
wood bolted to the bottom because one of
the OG rules is to restrict just how low
the car can ride another safety thing
and so after every race they can inspect
the plank of wood on the bottom of your
car and if it's too worn down then your
car was dragging too low to the ground
and you have too much downforce and your
car is illegal disqualified so just
think about that next time you see one
of those jet looking Marvel of
engineering carbon fiber masterpieces
flying around the racetrack just know
that every single one of them also has a
plank of wood bolted to the bottom of it
so you've got this rule book everybody
knows the rules and then you've got all
these teams independently working
spending millions of dollars to try to
find any experiment any little thing
that might give their car the advantage
around the track and naturally since
it's so competitive these teams are
incredibly secretive about everything
they're doing but then the beautiful
thing is if some team actually comes up
with something that's good enough to
give them a real Advantage even if it's
a tenth of a second a quarter of a
second a half a second per lap that's
massive eventually all the other teams
will pick up on it and will find a way
to build it and implement it themselves
it's just this ecosystem of all these
constantly improving features and you
can see them stacking on top of each
other over and over again so what
exactly are these improvements you might
be wondering great question here are
some of the biggest ones and basically
every single one of these has an amazing
story behind it of how someone on an
engineering team had an idea and then
they decided to try it and then it
worked and it stuck so one of the most
obvious is the wings right of course we
see Wings everywhere on today's cars but
believe it or not F1 cars didn't always
have wings they just relied on pure
mechanical grip from the tires but you
know how if you stick your hand out the
car window and then tilt it it'll push
your hand up or down same thing with a
wing on a car it can push parts of the
car up or down into the track for more
grip and faster cornering so it started
off as a very small experiment on the
front axle and very quickly it started
working and now they all have front
wings and rear Wings fun fact one team
did actually once try a mini extra front
wing on a car in 2001 it didn't really
work out so you don't really see that
anymore the cars today have tons and
tons of aerodynamic features
multi-layered front Wings small air
steering little bits like fins near the
middle of the car it's crazy how many
details there are if you ever actually
get to look at one of these things
another huge advancement is something
called Kur an acronym for kinetic energy
recovery system basically a system to
capture energy created by the spinning
wheel and turns it into energy in a
battery that can be deployed as boosts
later so the first teams to try this
kind of stuff they actually found it was
a little bit too heavy and it worked
kind of sometimes didn't necessarily
guarantee a win but eventually fast
forward a couple years and it's
developed over time and paved the way
for today's hybrid F1 cars now you might
have also heard of this one DRS this
one's pretty simple actually so yeah
there's a ton of downforce from the
aerodynamic features of this car and
that helps it stick to the ground during
these planted turns but that actually
technically slows it down in a straight
line so teams engineered a drag
reduction system a button that you press
that changes the arrow of the car opens
up lets it cut through the air more
quickly and it works really well so at
this point not only do all the cars have
it but it's actually literally written
into the rules when you can use it to
maximize racing excitement there have
been plenty of other massive
technological innovations over the years
that have all been pioneered by just
some engineer on a team who had a good
idea that have turned out to be huge
from putting the engine behind the
driver to the monoco chassis to the
ground effect aerodynamics to paddle
shifters all of them adding up to
absolutely insane cars of today in 2023
these cars are clawing for maximum grip
around every corner they're hitting 200
plus mph in straightaways and then
pulling five to six G's under breaking
and
turning five to six
G's is about as much as you can feel
anywhere on Earth other than an airplane
so this is why F1 is often called The
Pinnacle of Motorsports and I totally
agree like there are technically cars
that are a little bit faster in a
straight line from a standstill you
might see some of these videos on
YouTube my car actually is but the
second you get to a turn it gets really
obvious the difference in braking grip
acceleration out of a corner just the
control you have over the car it's
honestly incredible and it's it's one
thing to see it on TV like you can tell
they're going pretty fast and the
broadcasts are super cool there's sensor
data everywhere live speed readouts
cameras on every car but seeing it in
person gave me an entirely new level of
respect for all of it so this is the
Ferrari car the day before racing
started this past weekend in Las Vegas
this car is so much lower and actually
bigger than you might expect it to be
there was also so many little
aerodynamic shapes and pieces and carbon
fiber everywhere as I mentioned before
the tires are also gigantic and the
driver it's so much lower than you might
expect actually bid Defender also let me
try a full-on F1 simulator in their
performance zone out here in Vegas and
the most noticeable thing actually is
just how low you sit your feet are kind
of back up in the air right below eye
level which is where the pedals are in
the car it's just funny picturing all
the drivers now in their cars like this
but what really got me is just seeing
how fast they move I cameras just don't
do it justice I promise it's really
really impressive stuff and then there's
obviously the noise and the smells and
the the vibration through your chest
like none of that happens through the
broadcast so when bid Defender reached
out and offered to get me to the Las
Vegas Grand Prix to help make this video
I couldn't say no so this is the second
to last race of this 2023 F1 season a
super cool race built into the city of
Las Vegas like one of the straightaways
is literally the Las Vegas Strip and
points are available for the driver's
championship and the constructor's
championship so what is a race day
experience actually like well here's
what to look out for so first of all an
F1 Grand Prix is actually a several days
long event uh first there's practice
days then there's a qualifying day then
there's the race day so the practice day
is actually just a fascinating thing to
watch on its own because it's a practice
for both the drivers and the teams
engineering the cars so there's a set
amount of time that these teams get to
send the drivers out in their cars to
see how much faster or slower certain
setups are they all go flying around the
track at once for the first time and
drivers will literally communicate with
their teams from a radio in their helmet
about how things are feeling oh you know
a little more downforce here would be
nice a little more stiffness here would
be nice so they might do a quick pit
stop to swap out not just a different
set of tires to see how those feel but
they might completely bring it back into
the garage and tweak some of the entire
car setup before they bring it back out
for another lap and try out some more
major adjustments all within the rules
of course you might have seen the
headlines this Las Vegas one the
practice day got a bit interrupted
because one of the cars went over a
manhole cover so fast that the ground
effect aerodynamic force from the car
sucked the manhole cover out of the hole
in the ground and damaged the car and so
they had to go around and weld all the
manhole covers shut pretty insane so
then the next night is one more practice
session and then qualifying so
qualifying is actually pretty simple
it's go out and set your absolute
fastest lap time with your car
Whoever has the fastest lap time will
start the race in first place and
whoever has the slowest lap time will
start in last place so even this gets
pretty exciting because once again
everyone is out here now trying to set
their qualifying lap as fast as possible
and they're all trying at once so
sometimes there's a little traffic or a
little bit of drama and there's actually
three qualifying sessions in a row
elimination style so you start with 20
drivers the first session eliminates the
slowest five the second session which is
a little shorter eliminates the next
slowest 5 and then the third and final
session is the top 10 fastest laps in
order from 1 through 10 and so everyone
is after that precious first spot on the
grid AKA pull position I think the real
time all the data I went down to the
garage when they were starting
qualifying those guys are looking at
monitors with everything about the car
in real time as it's driving on a graph
being traced on a screen it's sick it's
a science fair so there's no screens out
here so you're going to have to follow
like on the app you can only see the
finish line but final qualifying Ferrari
1 Ferrari 2 I didn't plan that they're
just fast so then the third and final
day of the Grand Prix is the race and a
lot of people will not get to go to an
F1 race in person but it is really
intense like every they're all dialed in
now they're all rolling out their
absolute best and final version of the
science fair project with their best
pilots and they're all going to now pit
him against each other so race is
typically about 90 minutes it's always
190 mi in this case 50 laps and if
you're doing the math in your head yes
that does mean they're averaging well
over 100 mph for the entire race pit
stops included but then actually one key
thing to look out for while you're
watching the race is Pit Stop strategy
so most pit stops during an F1 race are
super quick 2 to 4 seconds and it's
mostly Just Tires now they are capable
of doing some more extensive repairs
during pit stops but those also
definitely take longer so sometimes if
you have like a damaged Wing or
something they'll just continue on with
it because it's faster to not actually
replace it the winner of the race this
week actually did that and so one of the
last biggest rules in F1 that I haven't
even mentioned yet amazingly is the
tires so there's a predefined set of
tires available to all of the cars that
are again not designed by the teams
they're spec by the FIA under the rules
to be exciting for racing and basically
there's a set of them ranging from
softest and grippiest all the way to
hardest and most durable depending on
the rubber compound so the softest tires
are going to be by far the grippiest and
fastest around the track they can be
good for a few seconds faster per lap
but believe it or not they're so soft
that they will wear down incredibly
quickly and can be completely cooked in
10 to 20 laps and so you will need to do
a pit stop which will cost you a little
bit of time but then the hardest
compounds are technically slower per lap
less grip but they can go way more laps
without a pit stop so these drivers are
not only jocking for position to drive
their best but teams are also putting
together Pit Stop strategies because
every car is required by the rules to
use at least two different tire
compounds during the race which produces
a lot of really fascinating scenarios
where one driver is ending the race with
a different set of tires than another
depending on their strategy it is wild
it's super interesting to watch it's
like chess but the pieces are moving at
200 M hour and in curves and everything
it's amazing it's it's another reason
why Bit Defender aligns itself so well
with this stuff because again they're a
leader in cyber security in cyber
security you have to respond you have a
strategy to start things but things can
go very wrong and so they have to be
able to adapt in real time and that's a
lot of the same things these drivers are
doing that these teams are doing when
strategies fall apart they got to tweak
things they got to adjust they got to
edit it's Al it's very complicated so
there's all this technology all this
strategy all of these incredible
machines but at the end of the day you
just got to get out there and win the
race you know so get in the slipstream
play defense attack breaking zones use
your machine's specific advantages to
get that rare overtake and just all of
this being put together it's like art on
Wheels there's plenty of YouTube clips
out there there's a Netflix documentary
you've probably heard about it is
amazing to watch and then the cherry on
top for me is all the effects that
Formula 1 has on the world outside of
Formula 1 it's a bigger thing you might
think like the obvious one is that okay
some of the highest end most amazing
Innovations from trying to make the F1
cars faster will eventually maybe
trickle down into the road cars that we
have today and that's true that's real
so the Ferrari team might find something
cool that works on the racetrack in 2023
and then in 2029 they're working on a
simpler less expensive version but
that's very effective for a Ferrari that
someone can actually buy DRS paddle
shifters carbon fiber all there's lots
of examples of things that originated in
F1 cars that have made their way to cars
that exist today which is super cool but
then there's some of the less obvious
things like a race kind of changes a
whole city forever kind of like the
Olympics now a lot of races are on
dedicated purpose-built racetracks so
the effect's not as huge but there are a
few special races during the season that
are built into the city streets which
are way cooler in my opinion even if
they present a number of very unique
challenges and then the winning or even
just participating is a huge marketing
win for all of these companies obviously
if you have a team dedicated to the
highest end of Motorsport pushing the
envelope with Innovation and
Engineering the ad copy basically writes
itself so thanks again to bid Defender
and team Ferrari for helping make this
video possible I got to learn a lot
about them too and actually the fact
that Bit Defender technology is actually
used by Ferrari to protect their top
secret Innovations but now I'm a fan I'm
going to be watching F1 I hope you
enjoyed this video I my goal for this
whole thing was to hopefully have you be
able to watch a video watch an F1 race
and not necessarily know everything
that's going on but to be able to better
appreciate the race and the engineering
and the spectacle of what might happen
next thanks for watching subscribe for
more catch you in the next one
peace oh